[Musique]
notre amitié qui est Nicolas Tenzer
bonjour Merci d'être à nos côtés vous
êtes politologue spécialiste des
questions stratégiques et
internationales directeur parieur de la
publication deskuss Russie merci d'être
à nos côtés j'aimerais d'abord avoir
votre votre avis sur cette séquence
européenne qui s'est joué ce matin et
qui va se poursuivre cet après-midi on
commentait il y a quelques instants
cette cette photo de famille volody
mirzelinski qui prend place au sein des
27 pour pour un cliché ça on dit long
sur l'état des relations aujourd'hui
entre entre Kiev et Bruxelles
oui bien sûr pour pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que bien sûr il y a ce
processus d'adhésion prochain de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne la
l'Ukraine est déjà un pays candidat mais
maintenant effectivement les étapes qui
prendront nécessairement un certain
temps qui vont se dérouler pour la suite
et c'est vrai que l'Ukraine aimant de la
famille de l'Union européenne ça ça a
été clairement annoncé déjà lorsque
l'Ukraine a reçu son statut de candidat
et je pense qu'on va voir effectivement
des progrès qui devraient voilà advenir
dans les semaines qui viennent pour
avancer encore plus même si
effectivement les perspectives
d'adhésion c'est peut-être 5 ans 7 ans
parce qu'il faut reprendre ce qu'on
appelle tout l'acquis communautaire
c'est-à-dire des dizaines de milliers de
textes de pages de législation qui
doivent entrer dans le droit ukrainien
maintenant il y a un deuxième aspect que
le président Zelenski a rappelé c'est
que finalement
l'Ukraine se bat en quelque sorte par
procuration pour tous les Européens ce
qui en cause et c'est cela qui est
attaqué par la Russie ce sont les
valeurs de l'Union européenne ce sont
les valeurs de droit à les valeurs de
liberté les droits de l'homme les
principes fondamentaux des démocraties
on est dans une lutte contre on peut
pouvoir totalitaire de plus en plus qui
est la Russie et le principe de la
démocratie et on sait très bien que
celui créène n'est pas défendu
finalement c'est le reste de l'Union
européenne qui risque d'être attaqué qui
est déjà l'objet de manipulation de
l'information d'une guerre de
l'information de la part du pouvoir
russe mais c'est ça qui est vraiment
fondamental on peut dire que finalement
ce qui va advenir de l'Ukraine c'est à
dire sa victoire
ou malheureusement sa défaite mais là
encore une fois on est dans un une
volonté de victoire va déterminer les
décennies pour les Européens voilà il
fait de cette guerre en quelque sorte la
guerre de tout le continent européen
nous nous défendons nous vous défendons
contre la Russie et ce sont les mots qui
ont été prononcés en fin de matinée
devant le Parlement européen ça c'est
pas un discours qui dérange
non à mon avis ça ne peut pas être un
discours qui dérange c'est-à-dire que ça
renvoie aussi à notre mauvaise
conscience et ça renvoie à nos fautes
passer nos fautes passer c'est de ne pas
avoir alors que il y avait quand même
suffisamment d'alerte compris
véritablement la nature du pouvoir russe
ce qu'il voulait faire sa volonté de
destruction et c'est vrai que l'on
aurait dû déjà agir en Tchétchénie en
1999 2000 en Géorgie en 2008 déjà en
Ukraine en 2014 ou les sanctions étaient
extrêmement faibles en Syrie où je le
rappelle toujours le pouvoir russe tout
seul indépendamment même du régime atlas
de civils syriens et c'est vrai que nous
savons été passifs nous avons aussi
parce qu'il y avait une partie de peur
parce que nous avons été subjugués par
les discours russes parce qu'il avait
également de la propagande on avait une
cinquième colonne en quelque sorte dans
un certain nombre de pays européens et
bien nous avons voilà la été totalement
passif et aujourd'hui on voit un pays
attaqué qui a sub normalement plus une
centaine de milliers de morts en raison
de l'agression russe qui se défend
vaillamment tout seul même si c'est
aussi avec nos armes pour la défense de
notre propre principe et de nos propres
valeurs et c'est ça effectivement à quoi
renvoie le discours du président
Zelinski les Européens aller plus vite
aussi face à l'agresseur russe merci
nous offrir je le cite le soutien
militaire que vous nous offrez merci
d'en faire davantage nous devons aller
plus vite que notre agresseur notre
agresseur est en train de se mobiliser
davantage références sûrement à cette
vaste offensive redoutée par les
Ukrainiens à l'occasion du premier
anniversaire de ce conflit 24 février
prochain que comptent-ils concrètement
obtenir par cette visite par ce
déplacement en personne aujourd'hui
je pense que évidemment la première
chose et d'ailleurs c'est un message
qu'il répète depuis plusieurs mois à
tous les dirigeants occidentaux non
seulement européen mais également aux
États-Unis des armes des armes des armes
parce que si nous sommes sérieux dans
notre volonté non seulement de défendre
l'Ukraine mais de lui assurer la
victoire totale c'est-à-dire la
reconquête de l'ensemble des territoires
occupés et envahis par la Russie y
compris bien sûr la Crimée il faut lui
donner les moyens et il faut les donner
les moyens évidemment le plus rapidement
possible techniquement lui donner toutes
les armes possibles que soient
évidemment les chars lourds là
maintenant c'est acquis des missiles à
longue portée les Américains ont fait un
progrès nous n'en disposons pas
vraisemblablement en Europe pour frapper
le dispositif ennemi dans sa profondeur
et bien sûr des avions de chasse parce
que c'est ça qui va déterminer l'issue
du conflit le conflit ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui nous est extérieur
d'abord parce que c'est notre guerre
véritablement mais c'est aussi parce que
plus le temps passe moins vite nous
fournissons des
plus il y a aussi de victimes du côté
ukrainien et là effectivement on a des
semaines qui viennent qui restent d'être
extrêmement délicates il y avait des
avertissements déjà depuis plusieurs
mois des autorités ukrainiennes parce
que il y a une sorte de période de
césure ou effectivement il y a un moment
où les Russes peuvent essayer de
reprendre l'offensive et vraiment ce
sont des vies ukrainiennes qui sont en
jeu pour moi il y a un vrai problème de
culpabilité est-ce que finalement quand
on a vu toutes ces images de victimes
essentiellement civiles
ukrainienne parce que après tout on le
sait la Russie vise d'abord des
infrastructures civiles mais aussi
militaires dans les combats est-ce que
nous aurions pu nous Européens et nous
l'aurions dû éviter des dizaines de
milliers de morts et je crois que
maintenant effectivement il faut
vraiment mettre le paquet pour limiter
le nombre de ses victimes et donner tous
les moyens à l'Ukraine merci beaucoup
Nicolas Tenzer merci d'avoir été notre
invité le moment